[Applaudissements]
regardez il est en drapeau de formule un
vaccin l'ariary mais faites gaffe ne pas
être au départ vous avez un super
tischer j'avais un petit show ces qui
s'est passé car on sait qui c'est la
merde ça change
[Applaudissements]
vous croyez vraiment que ça peut bien
faire la trêve est ce que vous pensez
qu'il a la carrure d'être mon beau-père
et si c'est même pas faire un qui douche
c'est la prière t'emmerde pas avec sa
vague ou alors c'est pas trop dur à la
nouvelle famille ça peut peut-être mon
beau-père regarder le nom
j'ai contacté j'ai contacté la personne
qui m'a mis au monde ça finirait faire
oui elle ne soutient pas ça du tout cas
la nuit je vous dis oui je peux vous
dire vérité oui on va vous demander de
vous taire de petites routes et moi je
vais vous dire des vérités
alors dites moi la vérité je sais
comment vous ment 6,6 à ma mère n'est
pas une broutille
non c'est ce qui c'est sûr j'ai eu des
parents vous l'avez eue comment
s'appelle vers le marron pierre brosseau
c'est vrai alors enfin milliard au de
9,4 sur saint paul
mais du fait des débuts à vincennes
mais d'ailleurs vous étiez accompagné
déjà donc pas de jouer avec un ami à
melbourne en brasse beaucoup les amis
alors il est chaleureux vous dire la
messagère tu devrais être content mais
apparemment elle n'a pas trouvé l'amour
arrêter avec ce à quoi je joue a donné
un excellent score pour les
téléspectateurs
je dois donner mon magasin guillaume
genton et un crush pour la maman de
sacha c'est vrai oui voilà sacha il faut
savoir que mais c'est pas l'un vers ce
saisissement guillaume genton bien amer
je vais te dire la vérité sur la photo
on voit très bien dès lors qu' elle se
met déjà à genoux devant lui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle est petite de taille mais qui sait
on si petit que ça faut que l'année
prochaine parce murray passe temps et
pas toujours bien c'est quoi c'est un
ton club
c'est peut-être ça qui va plus et non le
brésil et du tout bas non franchement
vous avez l'air beau viril s'il vous
plaît donc oui mais voilà je me calme
pas cyril j'en ai marre je le dis
aujourd'hui je le dis la france
j'en ai marre ça vous êtes énervé je
vois là vous êtes quand même on
patrouille on est quand même en train de
négocier un prime time donc à bambous
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous savez que
c'est la journée de la jupe unifiée
[Applaudissements]
si les débouchés genre des souris ou
certains services un serment et bon sens
d'ailleurs sa maman oui un petit air et
oui mais sincèrement ça parce que c'est
vrai qu'à lille quel est le souci que ta
maman qui justement n'est plus avec ton
papa brink est une femme libre maman
n'ai vu qu'une vie de femme épanouie si
elle a rencontré l'amour dans la perse
en la personne de guillaume quel est le
problème
non non je ne vais pas bien dans ma tête
a marqué touche pas ma mère est oui
touche pas ma mère c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
10h10
est ce que vous avez envie d'aller au
bout avec sa maman il faut d'abord non
mais vous êtes en vous n'avez pas ce que
l'on croit que c'est bon pas trop là
pour le cos à dire à la france est
devant deux millions de spectateurs et
la vache en même temps c'est pas
possible ça se passe après demander si
lui aussi amoureux
non mais vous avez un vrai creux leur
moi je croyais plus en l'amour j'ai
rencontré caire où je ressens des choses
que je n'ai pas ressenti tue pas on s'en
sert mais après 6 et il n'y a pas de
réciprocité ça s'est passé lundi sur
cela il faut lui dire la vérité on
pouvait me dire la vérité mais la vérité
je la connais ne va dire je suis à nouna
je veux dire la vérité vous ne la
connaissez pas je suis je la connais la
vérité vous allez découvrir après les
vacances alors du tout je peux vous dire
que ma mère c'est pas été bien utile au
cas où cet été mais je comptais sur la
trame et d'habitation pourquoi pas parce
que j'ai pas du tout envie de thomas
bailleul mon pauvre tu te mettais pas du
tout sportif met alors à ce que j'ai
fait révèle tout l'été je sais pas enfin
qui font se baigne ses bons offices de
la faim sais pas pourquoi tu fais ça
alors tu vas pouvoir le faire toute
l'année prochaine
[Applaudissements]
nos chaudes oui alors ça fait depuis une
semaine que j'essaye de vous montrer ce
qui s'est passé dans les allées quoi
c'est son fond d'écran way au fond des
pensées mais vous validez ça valide mais
il n'y a pas d'amour tu reviens moi
heureuse je peux faire une mère heureuse
qu'une mère malheureuse et pas
aujourd'hui ma mère ne serait ravisé et
heureuse rendre à son enfant heureux
mais pas du tout il faut c'est d'abord
ça passe par moi et là on va juste me
dire quelque chose c'est un très bon
parti c'est une question financière s en
fout terme apparaît pas dans ça mais je
parle pour toi c'est quand on n'a plus
de travail
alors simple avec rafael beau-père
cotation avait on est en train de
négocier en prime time contre les
mesures adoptées
mais pourquoi tu me remercieras
sexuellement
[Applaudissements]
mais ce moment tél vous savez la
chronique que j'ai quand même j'ai des
très gros dos et sur vous il sert et
comment sait pas faire le malin monsieur
montiel parce que déjà vous avez ruiné
votre carrière sur tf1 mais la rue n'est
pas sur cette touche pas vous pouvez
toucher à n'importe qui mais il a écrit
quoi ici là monsieur montiel à part
faire des logements
je vois ma mère oui non je trouve que je
peux pas laisser passer ou fort ils sont
bons pour ester vous laisser leur est
passé ça allait mal à démarrer sous moi
oui moi et c'était aller à la dia
l'amour mais ma mère et moi ça déjà ça
papa tu aimais toi il faut que tu avais
il faut bouger grand maman oui ma mère
est une femme et elle est une femme qui
n'a pas besoin de guillaume genton ya
pas de librairie l'invité à dîner après
l'émission
le couvre-feu à 23 heures demain oui
estimé à 22 heures de ben ouais tu vois
je valide
c'est bon c'est très mal géré les deux
frères et soeurs comment les frères jim
pitts et rui pourquoi je sûr qu'elle
serait très heureuse d'avoir dit oui
c'est pas du tout son style excuses
moyen d'y arriver n'est pas de tout son
style ils peuvent partir en famille
parce que yom il a une vraie
responsabilité vidéo vous le voyez à
table vendredi soir moi n'ont jamais tu
vois pas qui est un mec qui en train de
sombrer total
[Rires]
tranquille donc scellé ça fait une
semaine que j'essaie de vous montrer ce
que pensent les français ah oui c'est
une émission c'est le jeu ballet
reviendrai
demain par une eau trop bien joué
puisque c'est la fin de la saison on
regarde et je me suis interrogé des
français on commence avec ce monsieur à
votre avis est-ce qu'ils parlent de baba
où la chronique heures hors garde qu'une
personne nous en pensée sans tout
bloquer ok je vais quand même la gauche
armes anti char et chaud peut-être avec
deux mojitos wayne la pécho c'est
peut-être pas baba mais décrit mon avis
un mode coop qui est dit leezam c'est
trop moche non c'est pourquoi nous
allons avec deux mois ça vienne montiel
eyes a bel et bien la pêche c'est une
belle femme et tout mais je pense y a
pas moyen
pourquoi h pour cela les hommes riches
ça me mêle avec battles est à vous
prenez quand même je connais un bon
marabout j'ai fait un bond de l'église
[Rires]
il est très bon lui la vie apparemment
elle faisait mais les hommes riches bah
ouais oui apparemment elles aussi sont
ils connus
connais pas mal vie alors l'armée alors
c'est vrai je vous dis avec des légumes
franchement alors là alors s'il voit ses
plantages compass on passe au deuxième
c'est une dame autres benhalima castano
apal est loin d'être une personne dit ce
que vous en pensez au caire ohlala j'ai
fait des tests alors je déteste je ne
suis pas du tout à la télé je l' ai vite
je le trouve arrogant
j'aime pas du tout j'aime pas du tout
bien parce qu'ils reflètent j'ai un pas
qui il est
c'est très moche si la télé c'est ça
c'est un match où il ya eu des gentils
mais j'ai pas garder plutôt si on
regarde cette personne c'est cyril
hanouna wiman malheureusement il est
connu malheureusement oui
objets de qualité quand même un cyril
baillie les humains il est vivant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et contient on continue avec les les le
troisième jeu prend 1,7 à cette photo
faut arrêter bosse dessus les troisièmes
ces deux jeunes filles très sympathique
mon truc personnes me disent qu'ils ont
pensé ok déjà c'est pourquoi je sais pas
en fait j'aime passer ce qui tisse
physiquement il ressemble à quoi un drap
je me les rats qui embête chinois ne
sait comment il ressent bah oui calvitie
calvi syrah et en plus c'est de la merci
de la merde moi je comprends pas moi
j'ai eric geboers mythique road ou bas
du pont vers el leithy l'adorent faveur
des gilbert deux ans que ce qu'ils ont
pensé sans keira et les trucs
ouais c'est omar a des goûts mais
franchement on peut même pas ce qu'ils
disent
tarantino
c'est très mignon illico de la mer à
l'est le quatrième avant l'autre je te
montre une photo tu me dis ce que tu en
penses
ok pourquoi ces cas au lit pourquoi il
est ko
enfin jusqu'au pour que les cas au
tampon rien n'étant pas ensemble non
c'est un bon gars c'est un bon gars mais
c'est un peu trop
aweys et ahmed baba ou l'autre regardez
les plus tendances
notre métier de kiné par la vérification
et le cinéma la question pensent les
guerres rhétorique qu'il arrête de
rigoler commun
comment jérôme ok mais en fait le show
c'est que ça en fait mais je sais pas
non mais c'est de la merde au caire
on embrasse la maman de sacha du tout
elle n'est pas dans ça et voulait je
vous dise oui un jour je la ferai venir
sur le plateau
ah oui avec son homme qu'est ce qu'elle
est belle votre maman en tout cas thomas
dans votre mail
comme son fils ou pas peuvent dominer de
photos la cinquième comment ça va ça va
et toi je te montre une petite photo
tunis que tu en penses
ah ouais franchement je n'aime pas trop
les donc pas trop fait pour moi fait
trop 10v ces boîtes avait pas trop de
tâches l'émission pour ce coming h
émission carrément pour moi je les
trouve c'est pas fou je pense que le mec
a pas trouvé la gema bernard montiel
aucun problème figurez vous qu'il y a
des surprises nordiste attend de voir
avant franchement exceptions qui l'a
très justement parce qu'ils croient pas
trop mais vas-y les bons coups ç'a
marché le régime ou pas petit tour
rentrer du tout où on a pu la merde ça
vous fait du début vsab à acheter pas
d'uv mois bon alors vous alors
franchement alors si vous ne faites pas
durer
[Rires]
tu as mangé un non non je suis maman
j'ai agrippante j'aime beaucoup mais
c'est la vie des français on termine
avec ces deux jeunes demoiselles
halluinoise elle je vous montre une
photo ou disposant penser en toute
franchise hockey à mais c'est l'époque
de mes comparses grands-parents
carrément on parle même à réal comparons
ouais je crois vous connaissez cette
personne qui est énorme amor carrément
j'espérais qu'ils doivent alors doit en
tout cas ça joue pas on regarde la
réponse cette personne c'est bernard
montiel mais je veux qu'ils aient un bon
matrimony beaux gosses sont pas vraiment
mon charmant mais un peu trop gourmand
nocturne
mais comme j'avais jamais finir ma
chronique
alors c'est à dire c'est à dire que si
vous faites le dernier manetons
maintenant ils voient rien demain alors
fait le dernier magnéto la bananeraie y
travaillera demain pour amener un truc
quoi au pire des cas on fera une
rubrique sur ta maman juste je suis
piger demain si c'est si oblige pas à la
chaîne locale oblige pas la question
parce que ça va faire des dégâts
témoin ce t-shirt monsieur jean temps on
voit le contrebassiste arrêter avec ce
avec ce tee shirt
elle est belle j'avais pas très
et si la veille nos touches toi et moi
pour être
c
c'est pas nous faire tomber lehman et au
ledemain aujourd'hui je vous le fais à
l'effet mais vous arrêtez avec guillaume
genton excuse moi tu crois bien moins
que demain tu vas revenir pour un
magnéto je sais pas vous l'avez jamais
fait n'est-ce pas lui parler 2008 et
s'agrandir ou l'asie sacha mbc
s'agrandir mais on va dire c'est qu'on
bébé mais je crois que c'est elle se
fait grandir c'est comprendre les envies
de sa maman envie d'être tranquille non
casser ces mamans envie de vivre un
amour passionné maman est très bien
moment elle a pas besoin de ça bon à la
maison ce soir
[Rires]
sa vie en main
[Applaudissements]